dès qu'une petite [ __ ] prétentieuse qui
devrait fermer sa gueule de dortan vous
nous l'avez avec la baie et bien des
dark eye des vérités c'est donc
débarquer des vérités je vous rappelle 1
le principe il ya des vérités des
questions qui apparaissent derrière
l'écran ou bien des défis et vous
désigner celui qui doit les faire il y
avait qui va devoir me manon c'est
l'insulté mais il a toujours rêvé de me
dire et c'est matthieu delormeau qui a
été désigné matthieu delormeau
je vous écoute dès qu'une petite [ __ ]
prétentieuse qui devrait fermer sa
gueule de dourdan on me dit ça se sent
pas bien
le vernis craque il a pas une petite
[ __ ] en plus nous qui va devoir chanter
harissa de khaled avec de larissa dans
la bouche
larissa est ici si vous pouviez mettre
matthieu delormeau ça m'arrangerait non
non non non non non non non non non mais
t'es vous mettez qui vous voulez thierry
thierry pasky by cc pas de problème pour
lui point cellule isa thierry chizat
thierry n'hésite pas le choisir comme si
ça ne payait pas elle était là sur la
côte est 2 mois sans un regard
moi aresa répand mois et dégagements qui
va nous dire quelques chroniqueurs
serais content de ne plus jamais revoir
s'il n'y avait plus tpm pays il y en a
beaucoup mais y'en a vraiment jamais
jamais jamais plus et mathieu paypal
very jamais plus ah oui ah non je peux
pas le blairer
ben c'est à dire que il est
inintelligent il sert à rien je n'aime
pas donc je n'aurai plus jamais le
revoir
qui va devoir faire un limbo à qui va le
faire donc un limbo avec un boa sur la
barre ces coins limbo chef limbo s'est
passé sous la barre mais y aura un boa a
loupé est-ce qu'on peut installer le boa
s'il vous plaît gilles mathieu bien sûr
mathieu mathieu mathieu non
c'est sûr et vous avez été désigné par
l'équipe
alors tu passes à quatre pattes et je te
suis moi je passe voilà je passe voilà
qu'est ce qu'il ya alimatou à dire ceci
donne un nom revient vers sa langue il
descend très religieux pertes attendues
yaacov ya ya ya juste une phrase de jean
michel jarre le relou d'eroglu est à
cannes dire que c'est le digital ex
pareil à l'espace vite à les y passerait
[Applaudissements]
à brighton au bas mot
et ça
bakou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]